il ya un an et demi on a découvert au
québec des animaux atteints de la
maladie débilitante chronique des
cervidés et depuis les dommages ne cesse
de se faire sentir en particulier chez
les éleveurs de cerfs rouges qui peinent
à écouler la viande de leurs animaux
[Musique]
dans le coeur des laurentides route 117
à mont tremblant ce dépanneur être des
arrêts obligatoires pour les chasseurs
mais cette année ça ne se passe pas
comme d'habitude des mesures
exceptionnelles sont en place en 2019
ici la chasse au cerf de virginie est
sans restriction
ce chef de famille sur un territoire qui
englobe 17 municipalités dans un rayon
de 45 km la chasse des mâles femelles
francs est permise et toutes les armes
accepté du jamais vu au québec
en fait le but c'est vraiment d'un dîner
dans cette population de cerfs au porto
pour la gestion du risque d'une les
risques la population s'y est présente
dans la population sauvage on veut
éviter à tout prix
6 200 inscrits
depuis l'automne 2010 8,7 une traque
urgence pour détecter la présence
possible de cerfs de virginie contaminée
est contagieux la maladie la maladie
débilitante chronique des cervidés la
mdc transmissibles contagieuse est
mortel pour tous les cervidés les serres
orignaux caribou et wapiti temps sauvage
qu en enclos nous sommes dans la zone de
surveillance rehaussé ou en 2018
on a détecté un cerf rouge d'élevage
infectés le premier cas a su revenir à
l'est de la saskatchewan
on veut pas se retrouver à être un
vecteur affaire d'introduction de la
maladie dans l'est du pays
pour la faune de la mdc est une hantise
dans les fermes d'élevage une
catastrophe
il ya beaucoup de séquelles de dommages
collatéraux malheureusement la mdc
détectés étaient confinés dans un selon
claude une ferme de
grenville-sur-la-rouge dans les basses
laurentides
un an plus tard tous les éleveurs du
québec on paie encore le pli ça veut
dire qu'on doit conserver des animaux
beaucoup plus longtemps que prévu
nourrir ses animaux l'eau et on n'a plus
de revenus pour acheter la nourriture
supplémentaire on doit même c'est cesser
paiement de prêts agricoles
malheureusement de manière brutale
tout s'est écroulé à l'automne 2010 8
sur ordonnance de l'agencé canadienne
d'inspection des aliments
les 3000 sert des troupes aura peu plus
grande ferme de saint rouge en amérique
du nord ont été abattus du même coup le
propriétaire est prouvée fermait son
abattoir des viandes de la petite nation
et après 25 ans la marque de prestige
cerf de boileau disparaissait
[Musique]
le fer de lance de l'industrie jour au
lendemain
c'est un partenaire c'est une référence
génétique au québec que nous perdions
c'est le rayonnement pour nos produits
de venaison de ses rouges que nous
perdions et par le fait même on perdait
un acteur majeur pour notre industrie
ça fait vraiment mal encore aujourd'hui
la maladie débilitante chronique à
partir la famille des encéphalopathies
spongiformes transmissibles comme entre
autres la tremblante du mouton
il n'existe ni traitement ni vaccin
l'agent infectieux est un prion anormale
qui contamine les clients normaux du
système nerveux de l'animal le cerf
infecté vient en mourir à ce jour aucune
preuve scientifique n'a démontré que la
mdc est transmissible à l'humain malgré
tout le marché de la viande de cerf
rouge d'élevage a sombré c'est le cas de
sylvie van der smissen de saint charles
sur le disque dur qui a perdu sur le
champ son unique acheteur
le restaurant de grands hôtels les
clients étaient très satisfaits du cerf
c'était l'art gros vendeurs les clients
est un trés déçu signe de par les
discussions que j'ai eues avec les chefs
par après mais la direction de cet
emplacement alors décidé de d'arrêter de
mettre le cerf rouge au menu un an plus
tard le restaurateur n'est toujours pas
preneur de cette viande haut de gamme g
teinté de recontacter 7h tard là pour
qu'on puisse refaire à faire ensemble et
c'était un an catégorie u10 corps n'y a
pas de quoi elle est pensée plus jusqu'à
maintenant on n'a pas de copine ce titre
non plus dans les tests
le seul moyen de confirmer si le cerf
est porteur de la mdc et de pratiquer
les analyses sur un animal mort les
prions fx yeux se loge dans les tissus
nerveux des ganglions lymphatiques rohff
a réagi et le bec à la base c est long
mais le deuxième grand guillon dans le
sac des prélèvements qui ont été envoyés
au laboratoire pour analyse
en 2018 sur les 3000 s'est rabattue des
troupeaux europe
les prélèvements ont finalement révélé
aux animaux porteurs de la mdc et les
analyses pratiquées sur les 3600 soeur
sauvages abattus dans la zone
périphérique de même qu'ailleurs au
québec n'ont révélé aucun cas de maladie
en 2019 il n'y avait plus d'animaux
porteurs du côté des serres d'élevage
comme ici à saint elzéar de beauce cette
virade l'os si vous pouvez vous en
procurer dans un supermarché une
boucherie une épicerie ou ans au
restaurant c'est parce que une
inspection eux des tests qui ont été
faites sur tous les animaux qui sont
abattus de plus de 12 mo mène donc y'a
aucun danger
la maladie n'est pas présent la
transmission des prions infectieux des
animaux d'élevage aux animaux sauvages
ou vice versa peut survenir facilement
car il arrive souvent que les cerfs de
virginie voisine les enclos d'élevage
les contacts possibles entre les serres
d'élevage et saha de virginie qui sont
présentes nature soit par la salive au
niveau des clôtures au niveau de murray
no border des clôtures donc les contacts
physiques de nez à nez ou juste liés au
matériel
une faille qui est présent se barre des
la gestion du risque a eu des
conséquences sur les projets d'expansion
de gates ont lieu où j'avais débuté la
vente du rin l'an passé pour la chasse
qui m'ont été interdits on comprend que
ça peut être un vecteur possible de la
probable création de cette maladie dont
c'était une source de revenus importante
pour moi pendant que le ministère de la
faune même d'urgence ces opérations de
détection
les éleveurs s'appauvrissent et encore
un acheteur dans l'industrie ils ne sont
pas beaucoup nous en avions quatre avec
la disparition d'un 2 les autres pour
certains ont baissé le prix de moitié de
notre coût de production et donc il ya
comme un refoulement en entonnoir vers
le seul qui maintient ch aux actuels à
un prix décent légèrement en dessous de
notre coût de production vieilles tôles
ou possède près de 600 animaux
un des plus gros troupeau au québec à
l'hiver il a dû se résigner à travailler
à l'extérieur de sa ferme
la nuit je faisais de déneigement le
jour je travaillais en forêt pour un
entrepreneur forestier pour essayer de
joindre les deux bouts nourrir ma
famille peut nourrir les animaux aussi
pour sa part sylvie van der smissen vie
des revenus de la production de grandes
céréales de la ferme
heureusement car ils déboursent de
l'argent pour garder ces animaux cette
année avec le foin qui est très cher ça
nous occasionne des frais s'il faut
faire avec son noeud pas de place pour
écouler notre viande donc on garde nos
ennemis
[Musique]
ce sont tous des femelles d'un an qui
sont prêtes à partir pour la viande
justement ailleurs au canada
la maladie est présente dans la forme de
l'alberta de même qu'en saskatchewan où
la mdc se retrouvent sur 75 % du
territoire aux états unis après
l'apparition du premier cas au colorado
en 1967 elle s'est répandue dans 25
autres états et elle continue de se
propager au wyoming le cheptel de
cervidés sauvage diminuent de 10% par
année
une hécatombe ici le ministère veut
coûte que coûte bloquer une échappée on
se devait espérer des coques se sont
produits en amérique du nord otan comme
exemple new york
on a répliqué ce qui a marché pendant la
scène côté qu'est-ce qui n'a pas
fonctionné dans les autres états c'est
la méthode de lutte de l'état de new
york qui a été retenu après la
découverte en 2005 de quelques serres
infectés en élevage et dans la faune
l'état a immédiatement ordonné
l'abattage massif la mdc a disparu on
vit avec les conséquences donc c'est
pourquoi qu'on est là qu'on veut
surveiller pour s'assurer que ces
présents demain qu'on écart est encore
capable d'agir
ok pour offrir dans la zone ciblée la
densité normale est de deux à trois
serres par kilomètre carré l'objectif de
chasse et de la rabaisser à moins d'un
animal par kilomètre carré densité
suffisante pour réduire au minimum le
risque de propagation tout en assurant
un bon repeuplement de bêtes sauvages
mon travail c'est de m'assurer d'avoir
des densités de population intéressante
pour la récole puis aussi au niveau de
la conservation d'espèces
c'est pas d'abattre des serres qui est
l'intérêt pour le plaisir de le faire
les éleveurs s'accrochent à cet espoir
que toute trace de mdc soit absente de
la faune et que les restaurateurs
distributeurs des transformateurs
refasse confiance à cette viande faut
tenir le coup
malheureusement plusieurs sont inquiets
il y en a certains qui abandonne la
production d'autres n'ont pas fait à
coupler leurs femelles demain matin si
rien n'est fait pour nous aider à passer
au travers
on sera plus beaucoup épaulée par ses
filles madame van der smissen ira de
l'avant avec un projet de transformation
à la ferme
c'est une façon de rentabiliser un peu
plus que d'être à la merci justement des
distributeurs lors qu'ils nous offrent
pas nécessairement le prix adéquat pour
couvrir nos frais
[Musique]
pour que la rdc soit considérée absente
d'un territoire il faut un bilan négatif
pendant six années consécutives on soit
parfaite pas avoir d'accord pour ce tir
de la nature puis fermé des lumières sur
scène au sénat mais c'est ce qu'assure
la gastro continue et va se poursuivre
au terme de la chasse et du dépistage
fin 2019
il n'y avait aucun autre cas de serre
contaminé ni dans la forme ni dans les
fermes
même si les analyses ne sont pas tout à
fait complété il y a de quoi redonner
confiance aux éleveurs je crois en une
relance
quoique d'allemands aurait-on trouve
seulement avant que ça la relance
revienne mais je crois que savoir année
on loge pas que c'est un bon produit il
ya de l'avenir pour le pour le secteur
de l'industrie de saint ruf
[Musique]
on